holmes
[Musique]
laurent du pont nord s'est passé c'est
pas qu'ils passaient là a dit me changer
de la confération dvb-t pas star labadie
on dirait un festival aux directives de
tébessa logo full aux as illzach
lâchez-moi agression soient stars mais
célèbre s'efface tard voilà moi c'est
moi c'est moi qui me fait pas confiance
eh ben on arrête tout j'imagine que la
prime imagine que tu encore plus tôt
prize a fait un titre hier ta famille
aussi
écoute c'est une petite chose c'est
tellement même projet d'un petit opéra
[Musique]
c'est
à toi
[Musique]
c'est cool d'arc
si tu buteuse excuse parce qu'on
n'arrive jamais embêté tous
tu enchaînes tu souris
moi le même problème tu souris tu dis ah
oui c'est encore un peu de travail pour
être un grand animateur
[Musique]
mais ouanna à merde il entendu oui oui
oui tu veux mon zizi oui oui oui oui
[Musique]